Flying submarines are a common idea both in
science fiction and in real life.
But this robotic insect may be the smallest one out there.
Researchers have built a small robot,
that can move as well underwater as it can in the air.
The small machine was adapted from an earlier
design that could only fly,
but in order to make it swim, they had to go back to the drawing board.
First, it needed help staying oriented while underwater.
The bot only weighs 175 milligrams, about
the same as a raindrop,
so to keep it from losing control, they added underwater stabilizers,
and slowed down the wingbeats.
When flying, the robot’s wings flap about
250 times a second,
To keep the robot from spinning around wildly
in the water, they slow it down to around
9 beats per second while submerged.
But the robot needs a way to get out of the
water once it’s underneath.
To solve this problem, the researchers turned
to electrolysis.
Electrolysis is a chemical reaction jump started
by an electric current.
In water, electrolysis breaks up the H2O molecules
into hydrogen and oxygen.
The researchers attached an electrolysis device
to the robot, as well as an electric “sparker”
When the apparatus is activated, the robot
creates a buildup of gas in a chamber beneath itself.
And when the sparker ignites, the reaction rockets
the bot to a height of 30 centimeters.
Even though it can’t fly when wet, the robot
can still glide safely back to land,
and when it’s dry, take to the skies once again.
While you won’t see this bot flying or swimming
in your neighborhood soon,
the researchers are confident that in the future,
this robotic insect could be used for help in disaster cleanup or environmental surveys.